[Music]
Universal Pictures proudly presents the
film you realized and absolutely no
dialogue whatsoever only after you
bought your ticket vey misra bla Blee
please told an award-winning songs of
beauty and exuberance except though
somewhere Russell Crowe I have made a
false report we may have met characters
often singing about things that could be
very easily done by just talking
normally water from the well why did you
go away seriously they sing everything
so to hit that point even harder
we thought we'd sing the rest of the
trailer meet the spirit of human
Redemption Jean Valjean a parole thief
now on the run another assumed identity
for reasons never made clear in the
entire movie who must face off against
Inspector Javert an officer with such
terrible priorities they put the entire
city Paris on lockdown the stubborn man
who already served his time follow along
in their epic game of cat-and-mouse that
spans 20 years which is almost as long
as the movie fears the Fantine her
random factory worker who brings an
incriminating letter to work for no
reason and is fired sinking into
desperation so deep she becomes the most
pathetic woman in France in just two
verses of song watch her with no hair
watch her with no teeth yes becomes the
most desirable prostitute in town which
you'll blame on Hugh Jackman even though
he had nothing to do did it's Anne
Hathaway like you've never seen her
literally she drops dead after only like
20 minutes of screen time leaving
Valjean to now care for Cosette her
precocious child who was scared of the
dark but totally cool letting some
stranger drag her around the city now at
the dawn of revolution one young man
will give up everything for a woman he's
met through a fence wrapping her heart
breaking a romance we know nothing about
because the entire subplot has crossed
over to make room for countless scenes
of Porat that since the Dark Knight
Rises as a movies been so manipulative
with its use of time germs and not since
Chicago has a movie tried so hard to
convince you that movie musicals are a
good idea featuring award-winning songs
but they all sound the same so about the
track listening you'll be able to tell
one song from another
experience over two and a half hours of
CGI crane
an extreme closeup
and the death of Russell Crowe's acting
ability story I really really really
wanted to win and ask
[Music]
I sure hope mobile agreed to thing until
your movie then initiative sham yes
anymore of Eponine Peter skater to spill
juice if your girlfriend doesn't
appreciate you after sitting through
this movie then you should really
rethink your relation
[Music]
less miserable x' well that was fun
now why not be a doll and subscribe I'll
get you my pretty and your little dog -
no soup for you I can't believe it's not
butter y'all gonna make me lose my mind
up in here up in here go ninja go ninja
go